bonsoir à tous je suis très honoré et
éclaté d'être avec vous ce soir pour la
48e cérémonie des Césars ça devient
dangereux de présenter ce genre de
cérémonie
t'es pas à l'abri d'une Will Smith
tu vois un mec vénère qui monte sur
scène il met une grande claque dans la
gueule c'est qui l'équivalent de Will
Smith dans la salle pour nous
deniminochet
tu imagines
une grande claque dans la gueule
c'est aussi que sur la fait appel à moi
c'est pour faire des blagues et pour
éviter de dire la vérité mais madame la
ministre d'abord ça va la baisse bien
mais on est le cinéma on n'est pas le
cinéma
on est le cinéma
et on est le meilleur cinéma d'Europe
même et je sais comment le rester moi
qu'est-ce qui marche en ce moment au
cinéma
avatar Astérix Top Gun des cascades des
effets spéciaux j'ai regardé le film
d'auteur
pas une cascade pas un effet spécial et
si et si on n'a pas le budget pour les
avatars pour des avions de chasse mais
qui dit ninja ça coûte pas cher des
ninjas tu imagines Vincent Lindon il
marche comme ça non heureusement vers
gilet de Binoche il se fait attaquer par
des ninjas de part et d'autre moi je
vous fais
je rajoute des ninjas Juliette sur la
vie de ma mère on fait un malheur
je l'ai vu le film bien sûr
on est là ce soir c'est pourquoi c'est
pas ce qu'on croit aussi au cinéma et
qu'on l'aime et dise James
et Messieurs s'il vous plaît faites un
tonnerre d'applaudissement pour
l'immense tard
sœur tout le monde ça va on se nourrit
du public on lui emprunte une scène de
sa vie et on lui rend l'image sur grand
écran alors c'est simple sans le public
il y a pas de nous c'est donc pour
toutes ces raisons que nous gens qui
faisons du cinéma ouverte
c'est qui le prochain Ahmed Sylla
c'est quoi le projet après on va manger
un tajine au Fouquet ça c'est quoi le
vous devriez en mettre un peu dans les
nommés si sinon ça va se voir que
quoi
excusez-moi pardon on me dit dans ma
narinette que
il faut passer il faut passer au
récompenses ok j'arrête les bêtises
merci d'accueillir ciel pour qui j'ai
construit un palais dans le désert
d'Égypte marraine Monica Bellucci
[Applaudissements]
numéro vous avez des nouvelles de César
en ce moment
oui j'ai vu le film
on laisse la place à la nouvelle
génération qui avec leur énergie et
l'air talent font la force de la Gaule
pardon
de la France c'est un synonyme marraine
vous pouvez c'est pas vous excusez
le César du meilleur espoir féminin est
attribué à
marraine
voilà merci Nadia
[Applaudissements]
très heureuse merci à ma famille et mes
amis pour leur amour et leur soutien
quotidien j'ai une pensée particulière
ce soir pour Denis Berry qui m'a confié
un rôle enfin mon premier rôle et ma
il m'a donné vraiment en profonde désir
de cinéma et je lui ai dit que César à
lui et à sa femme Anna Karina merci
beaucoup et le César du meilleur espoir
masculin et attribué à
Bastien
bonsoir merci beaucoup j'ai vu qu'une
minute ça allait très vite donc je vais
essayer d'aller très vite un César pour
avoir gardé espoir
même si j'imagine que
le plus dur est encore à venir merci
d'acquérir Léa Drucker et à mettre Sylla
tellement merveilleux de vous revoir
après
tout vous qui nous avez fait tellement
rêver avec ce film si ambitieux
artistiquement et à la fois populaire
rendez-vous compte Mesdames et Messieurs
que pour la première fois au César nous
avons un décor pour remettre le César
des meilleurs décors c'est historique
oui
enfin ce qu'il en reste il y a quand
même un bout qui est parti à Labenne oui
oui vous êtes un petit peu moins
fringants il y a moins de bras
pardon mademoiselle de vous déranger où
est-ce qu'on est qui sont ces gens enfin
là on est au César on est au César moi
j'aurais fait une petite beauté enfin et
le César du meilleur premier film est
attribué à Saint-Omer
merci à vous je voulais juste te dire
que je suis très très fière d'appartenir
à une gêne nouvelle génération de signe
astro française cette année j'ai vu des
films extraordinaires qui m'ont fait
réfléchir à aux possibilités du cinéma
merci on sera ni de passage ni un effet
de mode on est appelé à se renouveler
année après année à sa grandir merci à
vous les filles merci d'être là merci
de la meilleure actrice dans un second
rôle est
Noémie merle qu'est-ce que je me suis
amusée et je me suis inspirée de femmes
de femmes pour ce rôle de ma mère et de
ma sœur que j'aime fort et de Sanda mon
ami maintenant je pense aussi à toutes
les réalisatrices forcément qui qui
aurait dû être célébrer ce soir voilà
elle me manque merci d'accueillir
Charlotte Gainsbourg et dinos
chassant
j'étais mon cœur blessé l'amour comme un
boomerang me revient des jours passés à
pleurer les larmes dingue d'un corps que
je t'avais donné
je sors le bout de la langue ton prénom
presque effacé tordu comme un boomerang
mon esprit la rejeté de ma mémoire car
la bringue et ton amour le César de la
meilleure musique originale est
attribuée à
plein temps
avec une chose ne mettez pas la musique
maintenant ça fait 48 ans que les 16
heures du cinéma existent depuis ces
longues années 5 femmes ont précédemment
été nommées mais jamais aucune d'entre
elles n'a été récompensée alors ce César
je le dédie surtout à toutes les femmes
repentez prise la musique à l'image et
merci
pour remettre le César d'honneur à David
Fincher merci d'accueillir Virginie
Efira
[Applaudissements]
waouh comme je vous aime et comme je
vous remercie et je sais que c'était
l'Andam d'amour est partagé par toute
cette salle enfin des gens qui nous
regardent par le public français comment
ne pas être fou ça metteur en scène qui
sait si bien joué avec nos nerfs et
composer des images qui ne s'effaceront
jamais il y a quelqu'un qui a tenu à
être présent j'ai mis assez peu
d'oppositions je dois dire il se
revendique comme votre partenaire prime
Brad Pitt
[Applaudissements]
de faire un film de Fincher tout le
monde vous dira que ça en vaut la peine
c'est vrai soi-disant pendant qu'il
filmait la naissance de sa fille il
aurait demandé au gynécologue si on
pouvait la refaire
ça n'est pas du tout prouvé je ne peux
pas me prononcer si vous ne l'aviez pas
déjà compris j'adore cet homme de tout
mon cœur et même si c'est le plus
intelligent de la pièce il donne dans
l'autodérision et c'est le le
plus drôle que j'ai jamais rencontré et
je sais que ce qu'il y a à son
importance ce sont les gens auxquels
nous nous rapprochons
merci
et je dois dire que ça m'a pris par
surprise parce que les films que je fais
ont un peu tendance à être poil à
gratter et les discussions qui
commencent par l'ensemble de votre œuvre
ne peuvent qu'évoquer des images
d'hospices
qui sont tous parvenus à la même
conclusion lorsque des gens qui se
soucient profondément de la qualité de
l'art de littérature de photographie de
mode d'architecture de nourriture de vin
et de cinéma vous demande de venir faire
la fête vous y allez merci d'accueillir
Jérôme Commandeur
[Applaudissements]
de chez vous chers professionnels du
cinéma qui est dans dans cette salle
alors professionnelle du cinéma et pas
uniquement d'ailleurs je veux dire il y
a pas seulement des professionnels du
cinéma dans la salle voilà dans les
grands événements on a toujours son
petit quota de picassiette
vous venez pas Claudine on faisait la
cérémonie quand même
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure quand je suis
arrivé dans le dans le haut je raconte
ça
j'ai fait une boulette une toute petite
boulette et une dame toute mignonne dans
la file pour rentrer alors vous savez on
est là on sait pas quoi faire en ce
manteau dans les mains en piétine et
puis moi gentil je lui dis ah c'est
votre première fois au César il me dit
oui je dis vous êtes de la famille d'un
dénommé cela va faire quelque chose
quelqu'un de sa famille qui peut-être
dans quelques instants s'apprête à
recevoir un César là elle me coupe elle
me dit non Jérôme je suis la ministre de
la Culture
j'ai mais qu'est-ce que tu as fait à tes
cheveux Roselyne tu as tout lycée
elle me dit non je suis celle d'après je
suis après moi j'ai en même temps sans
vous faire offense même la ministre vous
avez une notoriété en devenir voilà non
mais
sans transition mais alors vraiment
aucune on passe au César de la meilleure
réalisation celui auquel il est attribué
vient le chercher puis nous on aura tout
le temps de discuter en coulisses
monsieur Pitt peut rester ne me gêne pas
quand je dis celui qui vient chercher le
César c'est que ça ne vous a pas échappé
qu'il n'y a pas de femme nommée à moins
que ce monsieur se fasse opérer entre
son siège et la scène ce qui est peu
probable
le lauréat sera un homme le César de la
meilleure réalisation est attribué à
Dominique molle pour la nuit du déisme
on a la chance en France d'avoir un
public qui a une vraie appétence pour
les films voilà qui sortent des sentiers
battus et c'est voilà une curiosité
qu'il faut entretenir merci beaucoup
merci
et le César est attribué à bouli Lanner
dans la nuit du 12 grâce à vous que ce
moment qui est totalement improbable
pour moi je viens de Liège quand
même
merci je vous aime
merci d'accueillir Benoît Magimel
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
je vais regarder ça qui m'ont sactrices
avec des sentiments
donc chacun de vos films vous avez
incarné vos personnages avec une telle
force et un tel engagement que vous
m'avez totalement emporté je voudrais
tant des cernes esprit à vous cinq mais
on me dit que c'est impossible et les
César de la meilleure actrice est
attribué à
Virginie Efira
chouette
en même temps j'ai fait
étendre ce César aux autres
réalisatrices
le César du meilleur acteur est attribué
à Benoît magimels
et puis
voilà tous ceux que j'aime merci
beaucoup
Mesdames et Messieurs le président de la
48e cérémonie des Césars ta rahimie je
pense que maintenant on est tous très
impatients de connaître de lauréat pour
le César du meilleur film le César du
meilleur film est attribué à
la nuit du 12 merci infiniment c'est un
prix qui nous touche énormément comme
vous pouvez l'imaginer dans le film de
personnages partage ce constat il y a
quelque chose qui cloche entre les
femmes et les hommes seuls les femmes
savent dans leur chair ce qu'est la
violence qu'on leur inflige les
cinéastes devaient absolument s'emparer
de ce récit nous en avions tous et
toutes très profondément besoin donc je
dirais vive les femmes et vivent les
hommes qui rejoignent leur combat parce
que ce combat nous devons le mener
ensemble merci
j'ai une pensée ce soir plus
particulière pour ces mêmes artistes qui
loin d'ici ou pas si loin d'ailleurs
meurt sous des bombes meurt dans des
prisons pour avoir voulu porter leur
voix donc je pense à eux ce soir et je
pense à nous en France qui avant de la
chance de vivre dans un pays où il y a
encore des médias libres et indépendants
où il y a encore des lieux pour montrer
les oeuvres pour montrer de la diversité
du monde et cet équilibre en fait il est
fragile donc j'ai envie de dire
protégeons-le vivre le cinéma je voulais
avoir une pensée pour la vraie Clara
c'est à dire la vraie victime de
l'affaire qui voilà qui a donné lieu à
au film voilà elle s'appelait Maud merci
c'est ainsi que sa chaîne cette 48e
cérémonie merci à tous d'être de rester
avec nous ce soir merci à l'Académie et
un Canal+ rendez-vous l'année prochaine
à bientôt